some people ask the question what is the
biggest disaster of 2012 if we had a
crystal ball well first of all let me
tell you what's probably not going to
happen in 2012 we're probably not going
to see Armageddon doomsday the end of
the world the apocalypse even if you
look at the Mayan calendar now if you
look at the calendars of many indigenous
peoples you realize that their calendars
were cyclic because they were very close
to Mother Nature very close to the
cycles of the weather the cycles of the
planet and therefore one cycle ends and
another cycle begins unfortunately I
think Westerners Westerners saw
something hijacked it realized they can
make best-selling books by talking about
the end of the world and the thing began
to have a life of its own so let's take
a look at some of these prophecies one
says that perhaps another planet from
our displays face will come near the
earth disrupt the whole solar system
well let's be blunt about this we don't
see anything out there at all in fact
you have to go way beyond Pluto before
you find objects that are the size of
Pluto and they are billions upon
billions of miles in out of space so
we're not going to expect to see that
happen another group of people say that
perhaps the earth aligns with the center
of the Milky Way galaxy where there's a
black hole well just remember that that
happens once a year and the black hole
at the center of the Milky Way galaxy is
tens of thousands of light years away
from us and we simply orbit in a stable
orbit around the black hole
now one danger however that we have to
look at more carefully than before is
the question of catastrophic solar
flares that's something that has been
pupu but we now realize it's actually
more dangerous than we previously
thought if you take a look at the record
if you go back to 1859 that is the
famous Carrington event Karen Kim was an
astronomer he noticed unusual activity
on the Sun and then all hell broke loose
on the planet Earth with regards to
telecommunications specifically
telegraph wires all of a sudden
telegraph wires that were dormant sprung
to life and would transmit signals all
by themselves
some places fighters got started because
telegraph wires were overloaded the
aurora borealis usually seen near the
North Pole was seen over Cuba for God's
sake and it turns out that you could
read the newspaper at night in Cuba by
the light of the Northern Lights well
I'm a physicist we can then use these
bits of information to go backwards and
calculate the intensity of that solar
flare and the coronal mass ejection was
incredible in fact if it were to happen
today which it won't but if it were to
happen today it would wipe out most of
our satellites short-circuit their
machinery we would black out our weather
satellites GPS systems
telecommunications the Internet
power stations would be vulnerable they
would also be short-circuited and wiped
out not just in one city where other
cities come to the rescue but in cities
simultaneously across the entire planet
Earth
refrigeration will be knocked out for
perhaps weeks at a time
there could be food riots as a
consequence ordinary simple business
transactions will be halted because you
can make a credit-card transaction
because the telephone wires are out
society as we know it will be thrown
back perhaps a hundred years into the
past
now of course we don't expect another
Carrington event to take place every
year but every 11 years the North Pole
and the South Pole of the Sun flip when
the North Pole and the South Pole of the
Sun flip it release a burst of
electromagnetic energy called the
sunspot cycle that then eventually hits
the earth we now know that if you look
at the solar activity the Sun these
solar sunspots are like rifles and they
will eject huge bursts of energy like a
rifle but the earth is very small and
outer space is huge so for the most part
we dodged the bullet but going back in
the history books we now realize that
many times in the past
the earth came close to being hit in
fact just a few months ago one of these
bullets grazed the planet earth did not
hit us
so the physicists of the American
Physical Society my organization an
organization of about 30,000 physicists
in the United States have petitioned the
United States Congress to spend a few
hundred million dollars reinforcing our
satellites creating redundant systems
reinforcing our power stations building
the protocols by which we can create an
electronic infrastructure that would
withstand another Carrington event no
one knows when the next Carrington event
will take place maybe in a thousand
years maybe in the next solar cycle
which begins in late 2012 who knows it's
Russian roulette but it means that our
society as we know it is potentially
endangered we are sitting ducks to a
potential giant solar flare